have you ever been on a shoot where you
froze yes where I've just get really
nervous and I just like feel like I'm
not performing yeah yeah I've actually
got I get nervous all the time I still
get nervous when I mom I have my own
show and pastor I 10:30 so on Wednesday
no I froze during the test of your show
I don't think you did it all cuz I felt
like you were really funny you urgent
you did you I froze you felt like you
froze I remember you telling me that
like I was so scared
thank you but I was so scared I don't
know what it was but I'm like maybe
because it was your friend that's what
it is because you're it's like we're
hanging out right now and you're Bobby
you're doing it every day now it's like
yeah it not only that is is I didn't
want to let you down you couldn't you
can't let me down I know but that's what
it was
friends can't you can't I know but I
felt that I felt I felt in his head he
thinks you vouched for him and you're
telling people he's really funny so if
he doesn't if it's if he doesn't hit it
maybe I let you down maybe I do I know
there's a point yes yeah maybe I let you
down by just not getting them to give
you an offer for I read for everything
no but you know what I want to read for
everything I don't I'd love offers all
[ __ ] day man
give me an offer you know why I don't
like that I hate auditioning it's sucks
I say I don't want an offer yeah because
when you audition and you get something
you know what you're gonna you know
exactly what you know yeah so that's why
I got fired two years ago in that job
yeah when you get an offer they expect
you to do we're right am i right when
you do an audition what he's saying
quickly is when you give the audition I
say that's the guy you know exactly what
they want you did it if you just get
cast and make the offer like it I could
do something what just tell me what you
want yeah the first day of shooting when
you get an offer is the worst because
that one teen movie I did in the summer
I did the scene with these young kids
right
and I remember the producers all talking
at video village and I knew it was the
choices I was making so you could just
say them
yeah I mean and I remember like the
tractor coming yeah it's just a little
too I think and then you kind of you
have that conversation and you'd rather
have just do it I haven't got okay
that's what he did and the audition we
loved it and then you move on
yeah right and then we had to create a
thing and it turned out to be fine right
we we can we found a happy medium but
that was only because I got a [ __ ]
offer now obviously if I got an offer
I'm not gonna say oh no rather read for
it I'm gonna [ __ ] do it
but I'd rather do the other you know I
happen on two years ago it was a big MBC
show called Mission Control it was a
team movies I mean it was a TV show half
hours to come with what's-her-name Fox
she's gonna kill me if she's listening
Ritter Krysten Ritter is brilliant and
bruce campbell listen listen we went
golfing together we went golfing
together or oh no we biked we rode bikes
around the golf course we got stoned
together and drink tequila he's a good
buddies awesome oh yeah sign my bursts
he's all he's awesome I'm trying to ask
versus evil did not see on your way in
his big I wanna know I want to be real
with you yeah my connection okay if you
ever have a thing will you invite Bruce
Campbell to a dinner or whatever yes
sharing about you - I swear to God I
won't bring anything from the side I'm
gonna be a cool really cool but he's my
idol done not being real what am i some
just telling you that it would be a
life-altering experiment
done I love that dude I've seen all the
evil Dead's a thousand Crisco County
Junior oh yeah Bubba hotep yeah yeah
thank you so make that happen for me
what are we doing we're over an hour we
are yeah okay let's do the question that
I just want to say this that when we do
a when we you know when we do our
podcast sometimes it we struggle to do
an hour with Mikey really yeah that oh
it felt
we could do to my manager he was amazing
that was amazing
have a round of applause for Mikey Mike
come on guys
[Music]